[Music]
hey y'all
your hair's all messy you should have
brushed it i had to appear as like ozzy
osbourne
in this one because this movie is about
like a devil child
well don't ruin it well too late
[Laughter]
i was gonna say before we started
talking about the movie i said this is
actually one of those movies
that i think is way better if you don't
know anything about it like going in
i hadn't watched the trailer or anything
i think all that i saw of it was
like i read like the one or two sentence
synopsis on there
but this is like i said this is way
better if you don't know what's going on
but it's hard to talk about
if you don't you know i kind of knew i
kind of figured it was something like
that though to begin with
i mean she's running from a group of
people and
it's obviously some kind of cult pretty
soon on
in it it's pretty good it's kind of like
i can see how i kind of see how this was
inspired by the success of her
heredity hereditary i think there's some
and like mid-summer i think it's it's
supposed to be kind of like in that vein
of things
just saying i mean it's not it doesn't
have that same tone
but it's that same kind of subject
matter yeah
yeah yeah i mean like i probably should
probably put spoilers on the title
because like i said this is one of the
movies that you shouldn't
you should just go into it not knowing
anything about it because it's like a
lot better but then like as soon as
before i even got a chance to talk he
said
well he said what it was and i was like
god damn it well you gotta talk about
the movie
i know you got to talk about the movie
yeah and there's
you can't there's nothing else to talk
about that's what it is yeah the
well yeah but you didn't give me a
chance to like warm people okay i'm
gonna let you i'm gonna let you well
it's too late
that's too late so this is a this is
called
sun son uh it's came out 2021 i think it
came out in february or march
and uh it did like some digital
platforms it actually even had a
theatrical
run i think uh briefly and then
i guess it was a shutter original so it
just came on shutter at the beginning of
this month i think or the second week of
this month
and um you just said you were scrolling
through this like hey that sounds pretty
good i'm like yeah right i've been
seeing like the little poster for that
so let's watch it and it's like this was
actually surprisingly very good i liked
it i liked it a lot um
actually it was directed by ivan
cavanaugh and i was like oh that's the
same dude
that made the canal which came out in
2014 which is also
excellent he's irish but this is uh he
wrote this as well but this is
and the canal is set in ireland but this
one is actually set in the u.s
uh no need for me too says isn't it too
early for a wig it's never too early for
a wig
i mean you know whenever you get that
kind of wig yeah
mood the wig wavelength yeah we went to
the club last night i woke up all right
feeling all right and just decided it's
wig time this wig time
there's another shirt got that perfect
[ __ ] hormonal balance going on right
now
that's the wig goes off well that's nice
yeah
it's like with your little cartoon face
with like a goofy little wig on it it
says it's wig time
yeah that would be funny you still
haven't got coming up with all these
[ __ ] shirts and [ __ ] for me i can't
remember them all
i know i can't either i don't have time
to make them all either it's like
sometimes i'm like oh that'd be a good
idea but yeah so uh so yeah so this is
directed by the same guy that did the
canal which you haven't if you haven't
seen that that's also really good it
might be on netflix i think that's where
i watched it
um but this is kind of this is
kind of the same thing in that
i mean it's not like really the story's
not the same
but thematically it's kind of the same
because you're not really sure
if the protagonist is
imagining everything or if shit's really
happening they do resolve it at the end
so it's not kind of like oh we left an
ambiguous type of thing they do actually
resolve which one of those it is
but um for a long time you're not
entirely sure because it could kind of
go either way
so this has um i can't i'm not sure how
you pronounce her last name but andy
matitchak matajak something like that
she was in uh
the 2018 halloween i think she played
uh she played uh jamie lee curtis's
granddaughter in that you remember that
yeah
and um i can't really like the name of
the guy that's in it
uh [ __ ] what's his name [ __ ] um do do
do emile hirsch
yeah and he's in a he's in a shit-ton of
movies too so he's also in this
but this really has this is the kind of
movie i think this is
um uh because the way tom reacted to it
i said this is a movie that's like
really good at your uh five or ten
minute rule yeah because this one like
sucked you in like right away because
like the opening sequence is just
really really tense and you're just like
man what the [ __ ] is going on here
you know what i mean it's like because
there's this woman and she's like
pregnant and she's running
and then um you know she goes in a diner
and there's like these two guys come in
and they seem like they're after and
she's like oh [ __ ] and it's like she
runs
out and then like she starts giving
birth in the [ __ ] car
right and then she's like no i don't
want you i don't want you i'm just like
oh i'm intrigued okay
so uh so yeah so then it kind of skips
ahead eight years
and uh so this woman is living in this
house by herself with the kid who's
you know presumed as the kid that was
born at the beginning and uh they seem
all lovey-dovey and everything like that
and it kind of goes along like that
until
and like i said if you want to watch
this go watch it like don't watch us
talking about it because
we're going to talk about a little bit
i'm not going to spoil it spoilers kind
of like hereditary
it's a live little movie it's alive yeah
and so i
i saw somebody else like uh compared to
that it's like the omen
oh yeah and the exorcist
all those all those damn satanic movies
that's all of them
yeah i mean this and it's a great scene
so it's like after you jump ahead
there's like this [ __ ] great scene
that was another one i was like what the
[ __ ] you know what i mean
it's like i don't know if i want to say
exactly what it is but she goes into her
son's room and she's like what the [ __ ]
and i was like what the [ __ ] i said out
loud
so it's like oh it's going in this
direction all right i'm i'm i'm on board
it's it's a good example of what i would
have been talking about earlier to where
hollywood needs to kind of go back to
punk rock origins in a certain way where
you don't need all this money to make a
goddamn gigantic blockbuster and all
this cgi
it's practical effects the thing's a
little budget but it's just shot real
well
it's got good acting in it it's got a
pretty good story and it like i said it
passed that five ten minutes rule
where if i if it doesn't pull me in
immediately it probably never will
uh this will pull you in immediately
yeah it really did because i was just
kind of like
there's a couple things like that birth
scene i was just like okay you got me
and then like a little bit later like
when she goes in the kid's room and sees
what she sees
and i was like holy [ __ ] there's a
couple little slow spots but it's not
bad it's it it's
it's in places kind of where they should
be a movie should have kind of a certain
pacing and tempo to it
i i liked it i think it was it was done
well it was pretty good
yeah it's just so like i said it's it
essentially it's a cult movie
maybe um that like i said they kind of
leave it ambiguous for a long time
where she tells like the cops
that are investigating the case because
the her kid um
starts to get sick his name is david
and he starts getting sick like with
this really weird
disease and like they do like every test
imaginable and they can't figure out
what it is and it's like it seems like
he's dying
and then suddenly gets better and
they're not really sure why
and then um she kind of confesses to the
cops she's like look i escaped from a
cult
like eight years ago and you're
presuming that at the very beginning
when she was pregnant and running that
that's who she was running from
um she's like and i think that they're
coming to get me
and coming to get the kid and so
that so it kind of goes on from there so
then she kind of has to
then they kind of go on the run you know
what i mean for a particular reason that
has to do with the sun's illness
which comes and goes which uh you know
which like i said i don't want to spoil
too much about it
but i just i don't know i really really
liked this and honestly
i watched a couple other horror review
uh channels like that i usually watch
that had done a review of this because
it's like i said it's pretty recent
and a couple of them i think sinister
cinema and happy wax like [ __ ] loved
it
a couple of other ones were kind of meh
about it it's like oh it was just so-so
but i mean if you liked the canal which
is it's the same director like you'll
probably really dig this one as well
even though it's a completely different
story but
thematically it's kind of like you're
not sure if it's an unreliable narrator
you're not sure how much of the [ __ ] is
really going on
but they do like i said they do resolve
it at the end so
yeah it's almost kind of like after that
it's almost kind of like in
three or four parts i feel like because
you know
you have the beginning like the prologue
thing where she's pregnant and
everything and then they jump ahead
and then there's you know that
thing that happens in the room and then
there's the illness
and then so that's kind of another part
and then there's a third part where it's
kind of like
on the run type of thing you know what i
mean so there's various episodes where
her and the sun are like
going various places like to investigate
things and trying to
evade the cult or evade the cops or
whatever
so there's that kind of thing too and
then it has
um kind of a big twist ending now some
reviews i said said they saw it coming a
mile away
i did not um i don't know if that means
i'm a dummy or what but
i did not see it coming i mean i i saw
like the end coming that they were gonna
like resolve it that way but i didn't
like
the twist part that the one character i
can't like i said i can't spoil it
but the one character that was more
involved in [ __ ] than you thought
i didn't see that coming because maybe i
wasn't paying enough attention i don't
know but some people said they saw it
coming but i didn't
so i'm just saying yeah i don't remember
exactly what you're what you're
referring
um yeah don't say it yeah i'm trying
it's i'm trying to think of a way to say
it where it doesn't smell
about it i watch the movie i just can't
i just don't really know exactly
one character who was not who he seemed
to be
that's all that's oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah
that's all that's all i meant right um
but yeah so
i would i honestly i would actually
really recommend this one i like it i
liked it a lot
yeah if you like hereditary you'd like
if you'd like to mid-summer you're
probably like it's kind of that satanic
kind of
cult thing going on and bringing in like
an antichrist or [ __ ] summoning
demons and [ __ ] like that and doing and
she summons a demon at one point it's
pretty cool yeah it's just like
you know it's not overdone it's not real
effects heavy or anything
yeah it's got like some gory [ __ ] in it
yeah but it's not like it's
not talking about like [ __ ] you know
cgi demons and [ __ ] tentacles
throwing everything around it's nothing
like that yeah they keep it pretty
located yeah it's pretty low-key
um but like i said there are some kind
of gory sequences in the sense of people
being dismembered and whatnot so
uh you know so it's a little bit graphic
in that way but it doesn't have a lot of
like you said it doesn't have a lot of
cgi it keeps that pretty much on
that would have ruined it well yeah that
that ruins a lot of those kinds of
movies where it's just kind of like hey
let's have this
cgi demon monster thing like come out
there and no they just stupid looking
they did spooky [ __ ] just with like
camera angles and sound effects and
sound
yeah which i which i always prefer that
that's just like kind of really
direct like things over people's
shoulders and stuff in the in the
background and you can't really see it
but you know what's there
that type of [ __ ] yeah see i like that
kind of stuff and like i said that one
great shot that like kicked off the
whole
holy [ __ ] like when she goes in the
sun's room like near the beginning
um that was just that wasn't cgi or
nothing but it's just like i was just
kind of like what the [ __ ]
yeah because it just i was like well
done yeah that was a really really
effective
scene but yeah i just i thought this was
a pretty damn great yeah it was good you
know
so it's it's on uh shutter it might be
on some other
uh platforms as well i'm not really sure
but that's shutter just added not too
long ago
so uh camp guy says put bugles on the
ends of their fingers for claws
what's he talking about oh he's talking
about the little uh chips
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah i can care less
about spoilers all knowledge is better
than no knowledge
in my opinion just saying i know but
it's like can't play the movie
yeah i usually like if it was old i
wouldn't care
but this movie like literally just came
out a few months ago
and so i know that probably a lot of
people want to see it and i
personally and i know not everybody's
like this because i know there are some
weirdos out there that
before they watch a movie they'll go
read like the wikipedia plot synopsis
i'm like why the [ __ ] would you do that
i don't really know
but whatever it's you do you but i
prefer to go into movies and books
really knowing as little as possible
yeah that was remember that little
psycho
that little psycho chinese chick that
we'd see at amc
and she would go to she had stubs and
she would go to movies almost every
[ __ ] day oh that little lady with the
blanket yeah that weird yeah and she's a
weird
little she was cute as hell though she
was weird though you know she was a
little bit weird she was calling me a
white male and chilly
and then she's like it's trying to get
all [ __ ] i don't know crt with me or
something but then she
before she would go to the movies she
would check chinese
magazines to read the entire plot
synopsis before she went to see the
movie
i've heard some people do that yeah
because she already knew the movie when
she went to go see it so there were no
surprises like
how could you do that she was like
doesn't ruin the movie because no
it doesn't ruin the movie for you no it
makes it better so i understand it
well see that's what i've heard because
some people said that they like to do
that because then they kind of knew what
to expect
yeah and then also like i said they
could they could
enjoy the movie without worrying about
what was going on like if they were
kind of out of it or whatever so it's
like oh i kind of like i kind of get
that
yeah but in another way she was like
maybe like four
foot ten maybe and she would curl up in
a damn
seat with the blanket yeah she's in
pajamas
she pretty much had her little jammy
pants pajama pajamas on
she was cute we talked to her all the
time because we saw her all the time she
in pajamas in the afternoon yeah curled
up and if i could be the only person
well she was like retired i guess and
she didn't really have anything else to
do she looked a lot younger than she was
yeah she was yeah she might have been
about 50 but she looked like she was
about
20. yeah she well she was like super
super small
yeah a little tiny thing and she'd uh
and she went and saw pretty much
everything she's
all killed and some of them she'd see
more than once i think yeah she'd be the
only person in the damn theater
curled up in a little [ __ ] like a
little kitty cat what are you doing
my chinese chick that was like so funny
yeah i forgot all about her
yeah i wonder if she still goes i don't
know
that's so funny yeah yeah we always we
saw her like all the [ __ ] time she
was always in there
but um yes what was i going to say
oh yeah so yeah i don't really get that
because i feel like if i see a movie one
time
and i feel like i didn't catch any
everything then i'll just watch it again
you know what i mean it's not like i
have to go the or then i'll go read the
wikipedia plot synopsis and go oh okay
now i didn't get that connection or
whatever but it's like reading it
beforehand just seems like very very
strange to me
because remember i think we were talking
about this the other day that there is a
subset of people
that are fascinated by horror movies but
are too scaredy cat to watch them
so they'll just go read wikipedia plot
synopsis of them and they'll go down
like this big rabbit hole
of just like reading all these wikipedia
plots and obviously but they can't watch
the actual movies because they think
they're too scary
which i think is [ __ ] hilarious i
don't know that's just hilarious to me
i like how camp guy put first down there
even though he's like
alright everybody press the like button
if you will please go ahead and hit that
like button and that subscribe
yeah robbie said little girl who lives
down the lane is also on shutter yeah i
saw they just added that
yeah we watched it on hulu i think but
it's not on hulu anymore but now it's on
shutter
speed shutter also yeah the one with
jody foster when she was kid
that like killed her yeah yeah or
whatever yeah that was a good one yeah
yeah i like that movie a lot um and they
just added
burnt offerings which is one of one of
my favorite [ __ ] movies i can't see
that again
i actually might maybe i might like uh
wrap up in a blanket like the little
chinese lady and watch that tonight
if you guys have never seen burnt
offerings that's a [ __ ] good one from
the 70s
with with uh who i call sexy ass karen
black is it
sexy ass karen black that's that's
that's her um
that's her title yeah it's because she's
got that kind of slightly lazy eye
yeah so it's what it does it just sets
it off it sets it off
there's a slightly perfection in there
just sets the whole thing off
but yeah they just added that they just
added
um near dark which we really need to do
a thing on because i don't
have you ever seen that it's a vampire
but oh it's good
i think maybe i have seen it it's really
good it's from like 87.
then i want to say 87.88 something
around there um i haven't seen it a long
time but yeah it's really really good
and uh yeah they've added a [ __ ] ton of
good stuff lately manhunter they just
had a man hunter
yeah which i need to watch that again
too because i haven't seen that for many
many years
yeah they talk about how they like i
said i used to like karen black wait you
don't like her anymore yeah yeah
not anymore well now because she didn't
because she's because she died or i
don't know yeah maybe
you can't like her anymore there's just
always something about her i don't know
if she had a lazy eye or
i or if it just could kind of see it it
always seemed to me like
one eye didn't quite always line up with
the other did you ever notice that yeah
it wasn't just my imagination no it was
cute
i liked it yeah yeah well it's just kind
of like sometimes
one of the little imperfections can like
make everything else look
i don't know just it's like that rug it
ties the whole room together
yeah i just wasn't sure if i was
imagining that it's like a gap in your
teeth
yeah right through it yeah i wasn't sure
if i was imagining it so i wasn't
in it imagine it imagining it
i thought she slightly had a lazy eye
yeah i think it is i don't know
i mean it looks like it's not
slightly aligned yeah there's something
about it
it's kind of cute though like you said
like a gap tooth yeah
yeah yeah like and like you said there
was always something kind of like sexy
about her yeah
just about if if i haven't brought it up
before
there was a great [ __ ] tv movie with
her in it called
what was it called the strange
possession of mrs oliver yeah that's
good
and um yeah i've seen it a couple times
yeah she plays
two twin sisters that aren't twitch not
yeah not really but it's a bit like i
said it's this movie and like i said
maybe i'm a dummy
but i had no idea like i wrote this big
long blog post about it like the first
time that i saw it because this
uh went in directions i did not expect
yeah like i didn't guess
like what was going on it's more like a
suspense thriller i guess it's not
really a horror movie
it's kind of creepy but you know there's
like a lot of creepy kind of um
she has like a lot of creepy nightmares
and stuff but it's i would call it more
like a suspense thriller but it's really
good like a mystery and like i said i
totally did not figure out
where like the the directions i thought
it was going that's that's not what was
going on
yeah and she was looking [ __ ] sexy in
that too man
now i kind of want to watch it again
i've seen it two or three times she was
she
was funny she could play an older
character and get away with it but i
think she was a lot younger than
than than she appeared to be i think she
might have only been maybe 21 or 22 but
she seemed like me she was in her 30s
in that movie yeah and it well it's
weird i think in that one
if i remember correctly in strange
possession mrs oliver
i think she was supposed to be 28
because i think they said that's what
her age was but she did actually look
older but not in a bad way
right she just looked kind of like a
school teacher
yeah type thing or an attorney or
something but she looked she looked
older
but she but like in a good way yeah like
yourself
it's weird that's weird moving yeah she
played a couple parts in that
yeah um yeah but she was around for so
long i think she was a lot younger than
she appeared to be
probably she could play an older role
and get away with it
yeah yeah but man talking about karen
black that makes me want to burn off
again too yeah maybe i can watch that
later tonight yeah i'll just like like i
said i'll get some snacks and lay down
watch it
uh luis said was she in the devil's
rejects she was in
yeah she was uh what was her name one of
the firefly
yeah family right and she was probably
in her 50s or 60s then wouldn't you
yeah yeah she still looked good mm-hmm
she held out held it for a long long
time
louie also asked have you seen the
original don't be afraid of the dark i
think i did but i don't remember that
much about it
uh yes she was in killer fish which was
on
mystery science theater the new one you
know the new mst
uh where they had to censor her
character's balls yeah she was in
trilogy of terror
she had a little zuny doll we yeah we uh
we did a review of that
um it's funny because that's the only
segment of that that anybody remembers
but the other two are good too
even though you kind of like know you
know how they're gonna resolve because
you've seen a lot of
stories like that since then but i mean
she's in all of them
which i thought was kind of a cool idea
they don't really do a lot of
anthologies like that anymore which is
like one actress like playing like a
whole bunch of different parts
i don't know that's a good idea maybe
they should maybe they should do that
yeah killer fish i'd forgotten about
that one that was a [ __ ]
who else so man who else was in that
i've seen that msg episode a couple of
times
but that was i think that was on the
gauntlet
or whatever i can't really remember
all right yeah she died in 2013 somebody
said yeah cancer i think
yeah yeah yeah all right so this hasn't
been all that long but
i'm kind of sleepy yeah and i got like
some
uh i got a poster i got to make all
right so
i guess we'll call it a day all right
and then uh tomorrow night's going to be
the side track show
oh [ __ ] man another night of drinking
that's what i was gonna say
our livers our livers are going yeah
well yeah because we uh we went to the
starry night show on saturday although
we just drank beer at that
so it wasn't like hard liquor yeah but
yeah we drank a lot last night but it
was fun though
it was a fun night it usually is we
didn't stay that late though
and man we were we were getting like
real hungry because we hadn't eaten much
during the day
so we drive home and the [ __ ]
mcdonald's by our house is closed yeah
it's always open i don't know why that's
always open
maybe maybe every now and then they have
to close it to like [ __ ] clean the
[ __ ] or do training or what i don't know
what the [ __ ] but it didn't look like
anybody was in there
nope and i was just kind of like i've
never seen that closed ever like since
it's been there
we were very upset so we had to come
home and make a hamburger yeah
cranster's hammer said trilogy of terror
made me pee in my superman underpants
[Laughter]
maybe too much information i don't know
that was a really good one
yeah so like i said sorry it's kind of
short but go watch the movie sun it's on
shutter it's really good
it's it's new or a burnt offering
there's if you're more in the mood for
old [ __ ] like i said i might watch that
tonight even though i've seen it a
hundred times but
i just reread the book recently as well
but uh yeah we'll see you guys uh
tomorrow evening
at 5 00 pm eastern standard time for
the sidetrack show so thanks for
dropping by and hanging with us and we
will see you guys tomorrow
bye